bravi ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono tali già oggi una partita
particolarissima chomon biasi e
giochiamo a nascondino
cos'è nascondino abbiamo utilizzato i
chip per essere impostori ma non è che
li utilizziamo le partite normali e
tranquilli abbiamo usato solo stavolta
perché io da impostore che tutti
sapevano
devo cercare di uscire gli altri una
modalità nuova modalità della spiga step
ora che portiamo in let's go impostare
cerca e sei tu tutti gli altri si
nascondono devono sopravvivere più tempo
possibile possono segnalare i corpi solo
per durare di più far perdere più tempo
ma tanto non possono dire che se tu
anche se ti vedono farlo e l'obiettivo
unico è sopravvivere più tempo possibile
nascondendosi loro anche se vi vedono
cioè se trovano ed ad allora possono
riportarlo ovviamente però non è che
puoi dire guarda è stato lorenzo lo
sanno già che sei tu perché sanno genere
che parliamo a fare quindi è quindi che
parla da fare niente ok
raga scappate
ciao pietro ti ricordi quando migliori
video amico mio vieni qua perché non
vieni qua amico bio vieni qua ti seguirò
per tutti gli ultimi secondi della mia
vita
il buon pietro va da una ragazza pietro
10 9 a 6
non so perché serve a 7 le trovo visto
step che andava in navigation laica
riportate le mille all'ora capitolo si è
salvato è morto sebbene non è bellissima
casa più bella io vi avrei giocato
scappato forse non sei in post limpo
strisce per si è già sicuro di aver
visto sfera ammazzare guardare porta al
passo sopra i colpi non era porta
guardo ces che c'è sconfitta riportata
io l'ho riportato invece scommettiamo
cesca e cesca e cercano vista la g
ma la dico di no pensavo che fosse
introvabile no no no ti prego ti prego
dio che si seppe stato bravo io voglio
farti niente però che noi ha
tutto liscio la porta chiusa che noi ha
precisato che sono maledetto sicuramente
troppo bello se gioco io non so che la
gente si è morto che noia è morto perché
no raga ma perché adesso tali centrali
stato difficile non mi vedo più
ebbene il martina è morta io ci sono ha
chiesto l'attività di agente azzurro ma
con l'azzurro lago scolari mareggiate
che stanno pagando i colori si stanno
facendo vedere tutti i miei ragazzi
della gente viva del gioco stacca
lasciare a tutti di sei vivo secondo io
sono dell evviva evviva lo schermo e
nero infatti a dire se è tranquillo
allora di roba non ti dico niente di
tagliare mai perso di vista
mi sa di no anzi sei trasportato club e
cioè incredibile comunque e inventando
queste cose subito l'italia ma non è
vero io costituite adesso sì ma come gli
venga il botto cosa va come va dai ma
cos'è la casa è un blockbuster va bene
raga no no no no la ti piace ti invita è
stato molto molto c'è anche la vita o
punito daddy dove si porta che ti
vengono a cercare a basta spegnere
no le lucine che ci hanno tolto le luci
allora fine in basso che voglio rifarmi
sei venuta meno obiettivo capire
qualcosa di più importante di cosa ha
visto non lo so non uccidermi però è che
così delicati camera di chi su nichi ma
nella vita ma guarda con fa mi era stata
la cosa più brutta da kill più veramente
gianpi metti una roba horror di
sottofondo i branzini cescat dai calcoli
di quale vai vai siamo salvi ancora
massini tiferebbe vicenda
o mio dio mio dio dai ragazzi ma com'è
possibile che ti trovi sempre latte è
possibile dove sei finito la tv non ti
vedo non ci sono più mi vedo più non ti
vedo più ci sono più
e scomparso non mi vedrai mai però di
ciaoblog come dovesse silenzio e dentro
le venete difficile attenzione cacchio
non ti vedo questa parte
perché siamo rimasti il proprio vivaio
sì ci sta ero vivo cioè dico tu fareste
siamo rimasti in due per non ci ho
pensato io l'ho aiutata dai hai vinto
hai vinto legge comunitaria
mi piace tantissimo ragazzi questa è la
modalità ascoltino molto strana molto
molto molto molto carina però non ho
pensato al fatto che rimanevamo poi in
due quindi alla fine vincevano in tre
non avrei fatto vincere poi decidi tu
vince la finale che tu dici mi chiama
fabrizio ci vediamo al prossimo episodio
iscrivetevi e bella ragazza
[Musica]